on va analyser tout ça ce soir avec
Héloïse zedom merci beaucoup d'être là
vous êtes associés de recherche à
l'Institut de l'énergie Trottier madame
mesdam bonsoir bonsoir donc on va
commencer par le mémoire qui a été
déposé aujourd'hui par Hydro-Québec qui
dit en somme le Québec est victime de sa
popularité avec notre énergie verte
énergie à bas prix sauf que c'est
irréaliste de penser qu'on va pouvoir
accommoder tout le monde est-ce que ça
vous étonne de voir qu'il y a autant de
demandes 23000 mégawatts tout de même
non c'est pas surprenant de d'entendre
ce genre de chiffres parce que comme
vous l'avez mentionné ni l'électricité
fortement décarbonée ce qui est vraiment
une ressource très recherchée en ce
moment où à l'échelle de la planète on
essaie de combattre les réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre un
prix de l'électricité très abordable
quand on se compare à l'international
mais aussi beaucoup de nouveaux de
nouvelles industries on parle par
exemple de l'hydrogène vert par
électrolyse on parle de la de
l'utilisation pour les batteries la
filière batterie on parle aussi
d'utilisation qui commence à augmenter
qui était
résistante mais peut-être pas en grande
quantité comme l'utilisation pour les
serres le chauffage dessert qui
produisent des aliments au Québec donc
toutes ces nouvelles demandes font que
c'est pas si surprenant d'entendre ce
genre de chiffre mais c'est quand même
énorme et Monsieur faitguiben on disait
nous a prévenu on pourra pas dire oui à
tout le monde clairement on a exclu on
vient de le mentionner l'hydrogène vert
on va devoir faire des choix mais selon
quels critère et qui est le mieux
outillé pour rétablir cette grille en
fonction de laquelle on fera le choix
des projets qui seront retenus alors moi
je pense que ces critères devraient être
quand même assez clairement établi même
si on peut se garder une petite marge de
manœuvre pourquoi parce qu'en fait les
les clients qui ont besoin de cette
énergie là doivent avoir un certain
niveau de predictabilité donc ça va
pouvoir se protéger faire leurs
investissements et pour ce qui est des
critères de on peut utiliser comme outil
une grille comme vous l'avez mentionné
et je pense que cette grille là comme
point de départ doit se dire OK dans par
exemple pour l'échelle 2030 2040 2050
voici où je dois me rendre en termes de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre dans
mon économie et ensuite on peut faire le
travail à reculons pour dire pour
arriver à cet objectif là quels sont les
éléments que je dois mettre en place
tout en englobant les autres enjeux de
la société comme
l'accessibilité de l'énergie pour les
familles qui ont moins de moyens la
résilience du système parce que
l'électricité va de prendre de plus en
plus de place dans notre système donc il
faut s'assurer de bâtir un réseau qui
tient la route un système énergétique
qui est fiable et résilient je comprends
bien les critères qu'on devrait cibler
mais qui doit les établir on a
l'impression que monsieur faitgaben a
beaucoup de pouvoir en ce moment il ne
doit certainement pas les choisir seul
exact il faudrait il ne faudrait pas
qu'il ait choisissent les je pense qu'il
est en mesure mais il ne faudrait pas
qu'il ait seul pourquoi parce qu'il faut
avoir en fait les le point de vue puis
l'expertise de plusieurs parties ça peut
être la partie du ministère la partie du
côté d'Hydro-Québec mais aussi des
demandeurs on doit avoir leur vision
dans ça un certain nombre experts comme
par exemple les gens qui font de la
recherche dans le secteur les gens dans
le la partie privée donc en gros de
nombreuses parties prenantes doivent
participer à la création des critères de
cette grille d'évaluation est-ce que
vous gouvernement madame Edom on doit
commencer à changer de discours parce
qu'on a beaucoup vendu à l'international
même cette énergie on a porté le message
d'une énergie
révolutionnaire or on ne peut plus
fournir à la demande est-ce qu'on doit
changer le message tout à fait on doit
changer de message parce que selon moi
maintenant la priorité c'est de
décarboner la société québécoise selon
moi c'est à ça guide au Québec doit
servir avant de pouvoir fournir des
nouvelles demandes je ne dis pas qu'il
faut arrêter de fournir des nouvelles
demandes mais il faudra toujours
l'équilibrer face qu'est-ce qu'on perd
en termes de d'opportunité pour le
Québec parce que ce qui est particulier
c'est quand on parle des 23000 mégawatts
là ici
ce n'est même pas calculé dans les
chiffres que nous présentait monsieur
Legault par exemple en campagne
électorale quand il disait on va devoir
construire un demi Hydro-Québec encore
et ça c'est
en excluant nos propres besoins ils sont
pensés à la transition vers les
véhicules électriques là qu'est-ce que
ça peut représenter pour nous pour nos
besoins à l'horizon 2030 à peu près avec
l'objectif de 1.5 millions de véhicules
électriques on parle d'environ 4 Terra
watts
à la consommation annuelle ça peut être
la moitié du complexe de la romaine en
termes de consommation donc on voit que
c'est des demandes non négligeables qui
s'en viennent et donc on peut pas les
mettre de côté sous prétexte de de en
quelque sorte subventionné des
entreprises qui viennent de l'extérieur
avec une énergie qui est produite et qui
est sourcé au Québec je ne peux pas vous
laisser partir sans qu'on aborde le la
démission d'Eric filions madame et
d'hommes qui a annoncé effectivement son
départ pour la mi-février dans deux
semaines votre réaction face à cette
annonce un certain choc parce que ça
fait une autre annonce d'un gros départ
dans l'entreprise qui est Hydro-Québec
c'est sûr qu'une entreprise ne dépend
pas uniquement de ces hauts cadres donc
ça veut dire qu'il y a des équipes
derrière qui continuent à faire le
travail toutefois c'est c'est au
participe à créer une vision et là en
fait on a beaucoup d'éléments de cette
vision qui viennent de partir donc c'est
à savoir quelle orientation Hydro-Québec
va pouvoir continuer à avoir ou
éventuellement changer et comment le
mentionner c'est que c'est un autre
départ ça s'ajoute à celui de ce
fibrochu et ça lui de jacinter la
présidente du conseil et on nous a
rappelé aujourd'hui qu'on est en pleine
restructuration chez Hydro-Québec il y a
les divisions production transport
distribution qui ont été abolies et en
plus on fait une transition énergétique
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là de qui on a
besoin ça nous prendrait un phare pour
guider la société d'État à travers toute
une transition en fait c'est là où la
situation est un peu délicate parce
qu'on pourrait s'attendre à ce que ça
soit la société d'État le phare on l'a
dit pour avoir la bonne direction dans
les dans les efforts de bicarbonation du
Québec donc c'est quelque chose à
observer de près et on espère très fort
que la personne qui va être sélectionnée
à la présidence de cette société d'État
va pouvoir tirer les bonnes les bonnes
ressources envers pour pouvoir
repositionner le Hydro-Québec comme le
phare de cette transition madame est Dom
toujours très clair merci d'avoir été là
avec plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
[Musique]